wir holen einmal ein Gesprächspartner
mit zu uns in die Runde und zwar
ingbert Liebing ja den obersten
Stadtwerke-Chef Deutschland sozusagen
schön dass Sie bei uns sind Herr Liebing
uns beschäftigt natürlich die Frage wir
kennen jetzt die Ursachen wir wissen der
ukraine-krieg ist für vieles
verantwortlich alles wird teurer Gas
wird teurer die Energiepreise die
Lebensmittelpreise also unser ganzes
Leben und ja wovor sich die meisten
Deutschen jetzt fürchten ist eben ein
extrem kalter Winter was können Sie uns
sagen können Sie uns sagen ja das
sozusagen auf wie viel Grad wird die
Temperatur denn im Ernstfall
heruntergeregelt werden
das entscheiden nicht die Stadtwerke das
Gute ist es gibt klare Regeln für die
gasmangelage wenn sie denn kommt aber
das oberste Ziel der Politik ist es und
das ist auch unser Interesse in den
Stadtwerken das ist gar nicht erst zu
einer gasmangellage kommt
aber die Unsicherheit ist da weil wir
nicht wissen was Russland weiter machen
wird Nord Stream 1 ist zurzeit in der
Revision für zehn Tage und Ende nächster
Woche werden wir sehen ob dann die Gas
wie vermengen wieder auf ein normales
Maß zurückkehren oder nicht sollte es zu
einer gasmangellage kommen sind die
Privathaushalte allemal die geschützten
Kunden das heißt die bekommen noch am
längsten Gas vorher werden
Industrieunternehmen abgeschaltet
aber was auf jeden Fall jetzt ja schon
spürbar ist das sind die deutlichen
Preissteigerungen
erlebt und bitte genau sie haben schon
von der von der gastmangelage gesprochen
von der Verdoppelung der Preise die
viele viele Verbraucher jetzt schon ganz
schön hart trifft wo geht es weiterhin
was müssen wir erwarten mit Blick auf
Ende des Jahres
zunächst ist es wichtig dass wir jetzt
im Sommer alle Möglichkeiten nutzen um
den Verbrauch von Gas zu reduzieren Gas
einzusparen denn über den Sommer hinweg
müssen wir die Speicher erfüllen der
jetzige Speicher Füllstand nicht bei
etwa 64 Prozent aber wir müssen auch
mindestens 90 Prozent zu Beginn des
Winters kommen wenn jetzt Nord Stream 1
kein Gas mehr liefert kann nicht mehr so
viel eingespeichert werden und wenn es
über diese Revision von 14 Tagen hinaus
noch mal länger kein Gas aus Russland
gäbe dann wäre es noch schwieriger die
Speicher zu füllen deswegen ist alles
das was wir tun können um den Verbrauch
zu reduzieren sicherlich richtig und für
jeden einzelnen lohnt es sich auch
gerade angesichts der gestiegenen Preise
die ja noch ja Stärke steigen werden
lohnt es sich auch tatsächlich für jeden
einzelnen geantwortet jetzt die konkrete
Frage noch nicht auf was müssen sich die
Verbraucher konkret einstellen wie stark
werden die Preise noch steigen sie haben
mit Szenarien ausgeführt aber woran geht
es was was erleben wir bis Ende des
Jahres
das kann zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt niemand
verlässlich sagen weil das ganze
entscheidend davon abhängt was Russland
machen wird wird es nach dieser Revision
von Nordstemmen eins wieder auf einen
verträgliches Maß zurückkehren vor vier
Wochen hat Russland die Gaslieferungen
auf 40 Prozent der Mann
normallieferungen reduziert das ist ein
ein Niveau mit dem wir auch schon
Probleme bekommen können im Winter wenn
es allerdings noch weniger wird oder die
Null Lieferungen der revisionszeit noch
länger andauern dann wird es noch
schwieriger aber das ist eben so dass
das niemand wirklich verlässlich sagen
kann das sagt die kann auch die
Bundesregierung und auch die
Bundesnetzagentur nicht verlässlich
sagen und das macht es uns auch in den
Stadtwerken nicht leicht zu planen
werden Menschen von den Stadtwerken
gekündigt werden wenn sie tatsächlich
nicht mehr zahlen können müssen Sie sich
darauf einstellen
das ist nur in ganz seltenen Fällen in
der Vergangenheit der Fall gewesen und
immer nur das allerletzte Mittel
wichtiger ist das vorher in der Tat auch
die staatlichen Instrumente
nachgeschärft werden das ist Aufgabe
staatlicher Sozialpolitik dafür zu
sorgen dass auch Menschen mit geringen
Einkommen ihre Rechnungen von Strom und
Wärme bezahlen können was heißt das
konkret das heißt konkret sie fordern
dass der Staat dann die Rechnung für
Geringverdiener übernimmt die ihre
Rechnung an die Stadtwerke nicht mehr
bezahlen können
ja sonst würden wenn es zu einem
größeren
Massenphänomen wird die Stadtwerke
wiederum in die Bedrohung gekommen
deswegen fordern wir auch weil wir
gerade Forderungsausfälle befürchten ein
insolvenzantragsmoderatorium und
einstützungsprogramm für die Stadtwerke
aber viel wichtiger ist es frühzeitiger
anzusetzen die Importeure zu stützen
damit nicht zu viel an mir Kosten an die
Endkunden weitergegeben wird und es ist
Aufgabe der staatlichen Sozialpolitik
zielgerichtet denen zu helfen die mit
geringeren Einkommen die steigenden
Kosten nicht mehr tragen können das ist
ein Thema von Wohngeld
heizkostenzuschlag meine Auffassung nach
sollten die Einkommensgrenzen dort auch
deutlich erhöht werden weil diese
Teuerung inzwischen auch im breiten in
breiten mittleren Schichten
Einkommensschichten auch ankommen der
Staat soll aus ihrer Sicht für
sozialschwachen Geringverdiener dann am
Ende die Energiekosten übernehmen es
zieht ja viele Rentner über die
Wintermonate in Länder in denen es
wärmer ist beispielsweise nach
Griechenland und in die Türkei ist das
aus ihrer Sicht auch ein gangbarer Weg
sollten das viele Deutsche in diesem
Winter durchaus versuchen um einfach
hier dem heizkostenstock dem
energiekostenschock zu entfliehen und
ist etwas wärmer zu haben am Mittelmeer
das kann nun nicht die Aufgabe der
Stadtwerke sein oder meine Aufgabe
solche individuellen Ratschläge für die
persönliche Lebensführung zu geben das
hat ja auch etwas mit damit zu tun ob
man sich überhaupt leisten kann
Herr Liebe in ganz herzlichen Dank für
ihre Einschätzungen zu dem Thema und
auch an Dich Jan Schäfer